this last year I've been collecting a
lot of pretty powerful data in terms of
loyalty trust engagement and performance
you know in this recession in fact it's
going to be a book with the Harvard
Business School press coming out in
October it's just called top talent
keeping performance out when business is
down very direct title so what have we
found out first of all the attention of
the c-suite
of business leaders has very much been
wrapped up in figuring out who to lay
off how to deal with the clamoring
clients perhaps you know how to deal
with the vaporizing value it's not that
they haven't had a very urgent desperate
stuff on their agendas but one thing
that does seem to have fallen by the
wayside is the nurturing of the talent
that you chose to keep and in this work
that we are just winding up what we find
is that your top performers often feel
very neglected you know teams have been
depleted they're also dealing with very
discontented you know clients and
customers their comp is down you know
their stocks are you know underwater you
know the list so if you measure loyalty
to employer trust you know in your
current company engagement with your
present job everything is plummeting one
rather you know amazing figure is that
top talent spending 56 percent of its
time looking for the next job that's a
terrible thing to be doing you know all
day every day week in week out because
you are being relied upon to fuel you
know renewal and growth for the company
or in so I mean that the very obvious
big recommendation of this book is that
you actually focus on the folks you need
you know to get you to the next stage
and don't assume that because it's a
difficult job market right
now somehow there you know captive
talent and they're gonna give 110
percent of their efforts because they're
kind of scared about the options out
there that is not true there is still a
lot of churn in this market we are
finding that top performance performers
are able to go elsewhere in fact you
know there was an amazing piece of work
published in the HBO our last summer
which showed that in the wake of a riff
a reduction in force which is you know
the euphemism in New York for a mass
layoff 31 percent of the survivors walk
out the door and it is precisely the
folks who don't want to leave those are
the the best performing of your current
talent the ones that can find you know
startups boutiques whatever you know is
the option out there but they are
finding those jobs so it is a danger
that you lose your best talent because
you're actually not focused on
motivating them right this second
because you're making a bunch of
assumptions about their stability and
focus which actually on true